Senator Marco Rubio joins me now Senator
I saw your Tweet earlier today but why
should any Republican be working on a
border deal with these people given what
their obvious goal is here and it's not
enforcement well first of all there are
things we need to do like improve our
Asylum process it's being abused it's
being broken has to be completely
reformed we got to get rid of this
parole program which is also being
abused I think it's like a 300% increase
uh over how any other president has used
it in the past all those things are
legitimate and they should be fixed the
problem is this the laws have to be
executed by the executive branch and we
already have laws on the books right now
I mean the laws have not changed from
the time Trump was president to the time
Biden became president what changed was
the way the law was applied and executed
the same laws Trump had the same laws as
Biden but Trump did not allow people and
discourage people from coming and we
detained people and we deported people
and we forced people to remain in Mexico
Biden on day one said I'm getting rid of
all the Trump policies in essence
they're not following the laws that
exist now they're not using their
enforcement tools now so what leads us
to believe that no matter what law you
pass they're actually going to do any of
the things you agree to all these things
do is it allows an Administration to do
something but it doesn't mean they're
going to do it so if they're willing to
go to the Supreme Court to fight against
border security what makes you think
they're going to adhere by any
legislative deal that's done on border
security they're they're going to take
the legislation and say well yes that's
an option but not pursue it because
they're not interested in Border
security Senator have you had
discussions with Senate
leadership um given your own experience
on the border question back in
2013 um with people like Langford
McConnell th um about the timing of this
and linking this with Ukraine funding
given where the people clearly are on
this issue of the Border they know what
is happening yeah what I've said to
everybody is to number one is if you go
back to 2013 you know 10 years ago now
that was a very different time we had we
had an immigration problem and primarily
it was the fact that we had a bunch of
people in the country that are already
here illegally today what we have is
something we've never seen in American
history you know in the month of
December 300,000 people on a daily basis
5 to 6 thousand people just walking into
the country every day and being released
and I thought think back to 911 right
when we had people that came here but
they had to pretend that they were
students learning how to be pilots and
that they're now they don't have to
pretend anymore now all you got to do is
cross the border say the magic words you
get given Asylum and you get to go on
airplanes without even having to show ID
well that's not stopping with this bill
though that none of this is stopping
Senator we heard can I just ask you
something really quickly so we're
running out of time we heard that they
might try to pass something in principle
without the specific details being known
or being able to be read by everybody is
that possible could they actually do
that it's possible you have to pass a
bill as you well know I mean as a lawyer
and you know you have to have a bill has
to have language the question is if I
give it to you on Tuesday or Wednesday
and I say you have to vote on it on
Thursday I mean especially something
like immigration law where every little
word matters especially how it's going
to be interpreted but all of this is
this this is all Biden wants he wants to
reach a bipartisan deal with Republicans
in the Senate you know then have the
house not pass it and then he can go
around saying look we tried the crazy
Republican MAA people in the house
wouldn't do it so now they own the
Border crisis that's what this is all
about well the Senate is setting them up
for that that's for sure Senator great
to see you thank you so much hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else